[Applaudissements]
il était certes moins nombreux que l'an
dernier à s'être réunis mais pas moins
motivé ni conscientiser coin tu vas lieu
de live depuis pas de planète ovale de
profiter de fossiles à vélo à pied ou
assis pacifiquement il tenait tous et
chacun à être présents la crise
climatique et aux cibles bien réelle et
elle doit être prise avec le même
sérieux que la crise sanitaire en raison
de la pandémie on était loin des
attroupements de 2019
malgré tout les militants ont trouvé des
moyens originaux et sécuritaire de
passer leur message
fidèle au poste
gray patoune berg était devant le
parlement suédois avec sa traditionnelle
pancartes
ti des sceaux
solfocus on being fille hôpitaux
manifestent
kevin distance plus de 3000
rassemblements étaient prévus
aujourd'hui et ce sur les cinq
continents
mais l'action la plus inusitée est
assurément celle de mia rose craig la
jeune militante et ornithologue de 18
ans s'est rendu dans l'arctique à 92
degrés de latitude nord afin de réaliser
la grève pour le climat la plus
septentrionale du monde au stade
car selon de nombreux experts la
pandémie de coronavirus n'aura pas
réussi à renverser la tendance du
réchauffement climatique
ici juni aimant radio canada montréal